continúa la información internacional en
france 24 y es tiempo de hablar de
economía estamos para eso con daniel
hablando aunque nos va a contar las
noticias más importantes de hoy en esa
materia daniela y hablamos de un informe
de la cepal que reveló una amplia
desigualdad en el acceso a internet en
américa latina' liliana muy buenas
noches mire el análisis lo hace en la
comisión económica para medir para
américa latina y el caribe justo en
momentos en los que los niños están
recibiendo clases a distancia y los
adultos están tele trabajando en varios
países esto fue lo que encontró uno de
cada tres de ciudadanos en la región no
tiene acceso a internet tampoco lo tiene
hoy es de muy baja calidad el 46% de los
niños de entre 5 y 12 años y si hablamos
de los adultos el 78% de los que tienen
trabajo no pueden hacerlo a distancia
todo esto debido a su condición
económica y social o el lugar en donde
viven y aquí viene la propuesta de este
organismo que cada país dote a sus
ciudadanos más pobres de una canasta
básica digital que tenga por lo menos un
computador portátil un teléfono
inteligente una
y un plan de conexión a internet liliana
cómo lo ve
pues me parecería que sería una medida
muy buena daniela y el club de países de
la ocde entró oficialmente en recesión
mire también es conocido como el club de
países ricos y este club en el segundo
trimestre del año tuvo una contracción
económica sin precedentes del 98 por
ciento frente al período enero-marzo
pero la noticia todavía es más mala y es
que entró en recesión y es más profunda
que en la del 2009 la caída en las siete
economías más grandes del mundo que
conforman el denominado g7 fue incluso
más pronunciada en un ranking que
lideran el reino unido con más del 20
por ciento francia con el 13,8 e italia
con el 12,4 una lista que se complementa
con canadá alemania eeuu y japón que
presentaron disminuciones cercanas al 9
por ciento la crisis iba a ser
justamente el tema principal del foro
económico mundial que se celebra cada
enero en davos suiza pero su versión de
2021 fue aplazada para el verano debido
por supuesto a la panel
daniela y hablando de países ricos
renunció el comisionario europeo de
comercio por saltarse restricciones de
el coronavirus cuéntanos mire que
afilian lo hayan visto con más de 80
personas en un prestigioso club de golf
en su natal irlanda hubiera sido algo
muy usual de no ser porque estamos en
plena pandemia del coronavirus el alto
funcionario presentó su renuncia luego
de varios días de indignación que causó
su encuentro social el mismo gobierno de
irlanda denuncia que violó las normas de
salud pública relacionadas con el 19
este funcionario es un peso pesado de la
comisión económica europea
liliana porque tiene a su cargo los
acuerdos comerciales internacionales y
ahora es clave en el acuerdo post over
exit en un comunicado de gm le agregó
explicó que lamenta profundamente que su
viaje a irlanda que siempre ha
representado pues haya causado tanta
preocupación y malestar y además
disgusto y también dijo que esta
controversia se está convirtiendo en una
distracción de su trabajo
bueno pues daniela seguimos hablando de
américa nativa mos argentina que se
encamina una vez más a una negociaciones
sobre su deuda externa nos dice que ha
sido recurrente durante este año si pues
menos de un mes después de sellar una
complicada negociación con sus
acreedores privados en turno ahora es
para el fondo monetario internacional
que es su mayor acreedor externo el
gobierno de alberto fernández le
solicitó formalmente comenzar a negociar
nuevos plazos de una deuda de 44 mil
millones de dólares que debe pagar en
los próximos cuatro años y que no tiene
con qué
mi conversación con kristalina georgieva
me alienta mucho a pensar que vamos a
poder hacerlo con una lógica común
qué es la lógica de no postergar a la
argentina y de no hacer sufrir a los que
ya muchos han sufrido saber que hemos
podido recuperar un acuerdo con nuestros
acreedores y saber que ese acuerdo no va
a postergar ninguna de estas inversiones
sanidad cuenten los indicadores de la
jornada pues a falta de unos dos o tres
cortos históricos hoy en la bolsa de
nueva york que se trata del nasdaq y el
standard poor's que avanzaron más del 1
por ciento en la jornada
este resultado animó también a las
bolsas europeas que tuvieron tímidos
ascensos y que esperan ansiosas la
reunión de bancos centrales de este
jueves y en américa latina hubo
descensos en las plazas bursátiles de
argentina brasil y méxico y la cita del
día son los 4 millones de euros que
costó la remodelación de la casa en
viena austria donde vivió así como un
freud considerado el padre del
psicoanálisis gracias por la información
económica en el 'ajuste de gracias
continúen con más de 24 punto com
i